how often do we embrace
self-transcendence compared to how often
we accept our own fragility and latch on
to prosaic views this question is
extremely challenging not only because
of its innate complexity but also
because its essence can be interpreted
in a plethora of ways what constitutes
of transcendence what constitutes
prosaic views for now let us leave this
EFT questions aside and focus on the
bigger picture life is struggle life is
struggle cloaked as a game it is cloaked
as such in order to help us organize
ourselves better for humans thrive more
on structure and less on abstraction we
come up with rules and laws and stages
and prices in order to create a more
manageable version of reality and forget
the struggle that engulfs it we become
part of a perennial game of adaptation
that attempts to alleviate that struggle
throughout that game we encounter
different players that try to tear our
inner world apart while we battle to
establish balance for balance seems to
be according to our senses the state we
seek the state we demand the state we
desire balance will always be the end
goal for humankind it is a long and
perilous journey that oscillates between
chaos and boredom but it seems that we
are on the right track to reach that
state the when is irrelevant what is
relevant though is the how and the why
self transcendence is the answer to
every question you might seek that is
connected to your search for inner
purpose and balance self transcendence
is the core vision every human ought to
have in order to explain his or her role
in this world whether this is manifested
by a religious approach a spiritual
approach or a materialist approach is
not of importance
the reality that this brought to the
table by our ability to keep pushing the
envelope of our systems and our desire
to transcend our human condition is the
gist of this idea this is the reason
that the personal development movement
has gained so much steam over the years
and it keeps growing in an unprecedented
way the need for every human that walks
his planet to escape the fragility of
this existence and become a higher
consciousness being will never fall out
of fashion because it is inextricably
bound to the core of our paradigm
philosophers thinkers spiritual leaders
and every agent that strives to add
another brick in the wall of self
transcendence is at the epicenter of
this Verity that's why we follow them
that's why we admire them that's why we
listen to them this is no joke this is
one of the biggest truths that you will
ever encounter and one you should
examine with enormous care the ultimate
virtue of a person is their ability to
speak the truth the truth mainly about
themselves but also in a broader sense
the moral truth and the scientific truth
morality and science are two terms that
have been flirting dangerously with each
other since the beginning of the
Scientific Revolution but never really
succeeded in merging or evolving
together there are instances of hope
throughout history which indicate that
we will eventually find a way to create
a universal moral framework free from
religion the draws depth from scientific
facts but this framework is still in the
making and it will probably take
monumental events in order to be
formulated throughout that process
however we are able to discover glimpses
of what such a framework should look
like we're all humans and our capacity
to understand right from wrong and moral
from amoral is expressed by our ability
to see cooperation and justice from a
very young
eh many through play this gift so to
speak allows us to build variations of
play as we grow older and the rules
embedded in the various games we create
help us assemble a version of reality
that is more manageable and more
relevant to our needs the rules and the
games are never perfect they're just
there to remind us that we need them and
that we constantly have to adapt them
and re-engineer them this is the
substrate of our evolution and this is
what allowed our species to survive and
thrive
unfortunately this ideas arcane for most
people either because of lack of proper
education or because of a proclivity
towards ignorant and a general rejection
of truth most people will cling to a
very trivial and oftentimes dangerous
interpretation of reality that will
serve only their personal short-term
needs since the ancient times people
have been facing the ramifications of
that situation and have been trying to
come up with solutions to this daunting
conundrum usually he had an approach
with the result in friction and would
create even more tension to the already
capricious nature of our relationships
so the wisest among us realize our
limitations and propose philosophies
that would allow the thinking human to
discover an intellectual solace one of
these philosophies stoicism it is a
philosophy so important that it has
withstood the test of time and it has of
late become one of the most pertinent
antidotes to the lack of control we
experience while we attempt to enhance
most aspects of our lives
Seneca I lived from four BC to 1865 we
don't know much about his early life
what we do know is that he served as
Nero's advisor from 1854 to sixty-two
and that in 1865 he conspired against
the mad emperor the conspiracy didn't
work Seneca was caught and he was
ordered to kill himself
we know Seneca many from the works that
are attributed to him his focus was
mainly philosophical essays and
tragedies in his creations there is a
clear attempt to empower the individual
narrative through a belief in virtual
presence patience and the embrace of
human struggle as an inevitable and Mads
needed tenet of life true happiness is
to enjoy the present with our anxious
dependence upon the future not to amuse
ourselves with their hopes or fears but
to rest satisfied with what we have
which is sufficient for he that is so
once nothing the greatest blessings of
mankind are within us and within our
rich a wise man is content with his lot
whatever it may be without wishing for
what he has not when you read Seneca you
can't help but feel humbled and
empowered at the same time take this
simple yet profound statement for
instance all cruelty springs from
weakness weak is dangerous because
usually weakness can lead to cruelty it
is because of weakness that we engage in
immoral and atrocious acts it is because
of weakness that we fail to establish a
canonical set of rules in our
relationships that can help them prosper
it is because of weakness that we fail
to see our own weaknesses and we stay
trapped in a distorted version of
reality that propels us towards misery
and distress Seneca knew that well most
probably because he could see through
Nero's cruelty and understand that
weakness is the source of it a strong
character is only cruel when cruelty is
inflicted upon
strength of character demands resilience
towards weak views and appreciation of
life responsibilities towards people who
admire you and a constant fight to
achieve self ownership this is what
Seneca fought for and this is probably
what he died for Epictetus was born a
slave and throughout the journey from a
slave to a philosopher him confronted
all the nuances that the spectrum of his
journey entailed that is perhaps the
reason his philosophy is so powerful his
experiences allowed him to live his
philosophy and use it as a means for
survival and prosperity the name I
picked it is in Greek means gained or
acquired I'm assuming that this was a
very typical name for slaves during that
time and probably a word that allowed
the picked it is to experience the
incessant death and rebirth of his
persona through constantly acquiring
more and more wisdom
Epictetus lived from maybe 50 to 80 135
it was released from slavery someone
after his 18th birthday and he then
began to this philosophy in Rome he was
considered a vigorous speaker that could
mesmerize his listeners and as one of
his pupils pointed out in his notes
induce his listener to feel just what
the Pictish wanted him to feel
there is only one way to happiness and
that is to cease worrying about things
which are beyond the power of our will
man is not worried by real problems so
much as by his imagined anxieties about
real problems philosophy does not
promise to secure anything external for
men otherwise it would be admitting
something that lies beyond its proper
subject matter for as the material of
the carpenter is wood and that of
statuary bronze
so the subject-matter of the art of
living is its person's own life one can
easily see that a picketers main concern
was how to adopt an intellectual
framework that will allow individual to
encircle himself from the limits that
are problematic relationships create he
was a firm believer of the fact that an
individual can only be free if he frees
himself from his limiting beliefs and
also his addiction to the opinions of
others he was one of the first to see
that there is a way for one to be in
control insofar as one can control only
the things that are within his control
opinions perceptions views beliefs
stories are all manifestations of how
our mind adapts to the stimuli of the
environment sometimes they're true and
sometimes they're untrue one can control
the extent to which truth is being
spoken by others but one can certainly
control the extent to which he speaks
the truth and how one reacts and
perceives the truth or untruth spoken by
others Marcus Aurelius was the stoic
Emperor the picketers in Seneca were
philosophers and advisors Marcus
Aurelius was at the top of the dominance
hierarchy and his authority exerted the
respect not just because of his power
but also because of his philosophy
there is something very crucial to
ponder the archetype of the emperor as
it has been portrayed through our time
is usually that of the oppressor or the
narcissist or the totalitarian Marcus
Aurelius convulses the foundations of
that archetype during his reign he had
to deal with a lot of challenging events
among which are at the war with the
Parthian Empire the pushback of
barbarian tribes the rise of
Christianity and the Antonine plague it
becomes apparent that unless you are a
ruthless ruler you can stay sane among
such precarious times Marcus Aurelius
did whatever was within his power to
avoid the ruthless tactics as much as
possible and follow a more stoic path he
was heavily influenced by pictus Rustica
sand Heraclitus and one cannot assume
more forward-looking and conclusive
philosophy in his aphorisms the
happiness of your life depends upon the
quality of your thoughts everything we
hear is an opinion not a fact everything
we see is a perspective not the truth if
you are distressed by anything external
the pain is not due to the thing itself
but to your estimate of it and this you
have the power to revoke at any moment
it is not death that a man should fear
but he should fear never beginning to
live very subtle optimism and positivity
encompassing his views and that's also
one of the reasons his dictums have been
more popular than the rest of the Stoics
there is enough ugliness and adversity
in this world to make us feel
demotivated in perpetuity choosing not
to focus on the agonist but on the
beauty and not on the adversity but on
the blessings is Marcus Aurelius way to
battle the motivation individuals can
act in any way they find plausible and
this allows them to
to benefits or to suffer costs depending
on the circumstances the responsibility
that our actions necessitate is the only
true weapon we can exploit in order to
antagonize the nefariousness of the
world around us Marcus Aurelius realized
the power of that weapon and that helped
him become an exemplary Emperor despite
adversity and despite his weaknesses
that is what makes him a respectful
example for all of us you have probably
noticed that all three major Stoics he
lived in Rome during the first and
second century AD this was the time when
the Roman Empire was at its greatest
territorial extent I cannot say for sure
how this affected the rise of stoicism
but I do know that during prosperous but
at the same time turbulent times great
philosophies emerge there is one thing I
know for sure though becoming enamored
with stoicism is definitely life shaping
experience hi everyone this video has
been a bit long but I try to present
stoicism from a more holistic
perspective
I added some personal commentary in the
beginning in order to reveal some truths
that stoicism attempts to convey but
very few actually notice I consider this
commentary essential because I wanted to
communicate that stoicism entails way
more than the quotes you will find on
the internet nowadays it is actually the
most potent antidote to human suffering
and if you'll also feel that if
understood deeply can transform your
life in monumental ways as always don't
forget subscribe smash the like button
and follow me on social media so we can
help this channel grow faster and give
me the impetus required to keep
producing quality video essays see you
in the next video
[Music]